an estimated three million people are
displaced
most live in the certain companies like
this one surviving as best as they can
waiting for help from the outside world
thousands are enduring the cold on the
waterless plains in al sharp camp
near the city of aden in the south
we are suffering due to the cold weather
we need blankets from organization and
philanthropist
there is no support for the children in
this cold the coronavirus pandemic
disease and malnutrition are all adding
up to make life here extremely difficult
we need a health center in the camp to
deal with malnutrition and also to treat
pregnant women
even before the war yemen imported 90
percent of his staple food
with but supplies are now cut off
a shop following the value of the yemeni
real has led to the
prices of essential commodities like
food and medicine sorry
in the absence of help from the
government and international
organizations
most people here are at the mercy of the
elements
the prices of everything have increased
even for bread and vegetables prices
have gone up because the road is cut off
so everything is expensive for me i'm a
motorcycle driver
my daily income is not even six dollars
so i cannot afford to eat
yemen has been mired in war since late
2014
when the healthy rebels seized control
of several northern provinces
and forced the internationally
recognized government of president abdel
rahman surah hadi
out of the capital senate
a saudi uae-led coalition then
intervened
with devastating consequences in a
country racked by
conflict no one knows how many people
are dying
from diseases such as cholera or from
the copped 19 pandemic
yemen's health system has all but
collapsed
across the country doctors say hospital
beds are full
and they don't know where to put the
second dying
dr abdullatif al talib is head of
sanaa's alfora hospital
the war has had a huge impact on the
health sector we've been
affected by the brutal aggression on our
country and the air and sea blockade
we suffer from a dire shortage of
medicines such as cancer drugs
open heart surgery drugs and others
unfortunately aid organizations also
have a monopoly on what support they
offer
and we have no say on what help they
bring in all this
leads to a severe shortage of service
whether in the authoria hospital or in
other hospitals
there are many causes of the war in
yemen but there are only two
consequences
death and the destruction of people's
livelihoods
muhammadu al-jazeera